pour l'instant elle présente plutôt
l'image d'une rue fantôme trottoir en
chantier maison fermée poussière
garantie mais après les travaux la rue
Leconte de l'île du port retrouvera un
nouveau souffle cette nouvelle vie
effacera-t-elle l'empreinte de le compte
de l'île
vous savez qui était le compte de Lille
non pas du tout un bourgeois gentilhomme
sûrement dans la littérature
on a pris un poème aussi je crois
c'était le manchi et je m'en souviens
pas il y avait une photographie dans un
livre avec le dessin avec le manche
et à Saint-Paul en 1818 Charles-Marie
René Leconte de Lille quitte la Réunion
4 ans plus tard il y revient adolescent
et la quitte à nouveau en 1837 pour n'y
revenir qu'au bout de cette année
mais son retour sera de courte durée en
1845 là d'entendre les cris des esclaves
maltraités par son père il coupe
définitivement les ponts avec Bourbon et
sa famille
installé à Paris il irrédacteur à la
Démocratie pacifique journal où il
affirme ses convictions républicaines et
anti-esclavagistes socialiste
utopique il se réfugie dans la poésie et
vous un véritable culte à l'Antiquité il
lance l'école par la sienne dont il est
le chef de fil
après le succès de poèmes et poésies le
Conseil Général de la Réunion lui a loue
une pension de 2000 francs en 1870 il
reçoit la Légion d'honneur
à partir de 1871 il est employé à la
bibliothèque du Sénat la mort de sa mère
les échecs de sa candidature à
l'Académie française et pour devenir
sénateur de la Réunion plonge le compte
de l'île dans la déprime un état dont il
ne sortira qu'en 1886 lorsqu'il est
enfin reçu à l'Académie française où il
succède à Victor Hugo
le comte de l'île me rend juillet 1894
et est inhumé au cimetière de
Montparnasse les restes du poète sont
rentrés à la Réunion en 1977 il repose
maintenant au cimetière marin de
Saint-Paul